so i was uh
mentioned
in the monologue andrew cuomo quit i was
i was reading his book this is his real
book american crisis leadership lessons
you know look up at 19
and having kind of a chuckle because
it's it's not aged well
this i mean this and i and i was
laughing and then i realized you know
what a lot of people write books and a
lot of them don't age well and we dug up
some of the ones you know from years
past you may have forgotten some of
these books but i'm telling you a lot of
books don't age well would you like to
hear some of the ones that i know
like
anthony weiner anthony weiners tweet
smell of success how to
how do you use social media to silence
your critics did not age well
uh michael avenatti's clang the next
time i see donald trump it'll be through
prison bars
did not age well
mike lindell's nowhere but up reclaiming
your integrity after a crack
never got a debbie
uh josh duggar's child ruining the
duggar way did not
[Applause]
you know didn't age well nick cage never
do it for the money
uh army hammers the people's diet did
not
[Applause]
[Laughter]
uh zeke freedom roy's no bad cats
training tips from the experts
but they didn't these are you
didn't age well as well
uh rudy giuliani's never let him see
your sweat
[Applause]